كده بالعوده الخبر العاجل وردته اكسيوس
موقع اكسيوس عن مصادر ان وزاره العدل
الامريكيه ابلغت نظيرتها الاسرائيليه بفتح
مكتب التحقيق الفيدرالي تحقيقا في مقتل
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله وقد نقلت صحيفتها
اريتس عن ان 57 مشرعا امريكيا بعثوا رساله
لمدير الشرطه الفيدراليه الامريكيه اف بي
اي ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي
يطالبون بتحقيق في قتل شيرين
واكدت الرساله انها شيرين ابو عقله كمواطن
امريكيه لها الحق في الحمايه الكامله التي
توفر للامريين الذين يعيشون في الخارج
وكان المتحدث باسمي مجلس الامن القوميه
الامريكيه قال ان شيرين لم تكون مواطنه
امريكيه بحسب بل مراسله شجاعه نالت احترام
الجميع واضاف ان الولايات المتحده لن تعلق
على مواضيع تخص انفذ القانون
مع عائله ابو عاقله حسب ما جاء في تعبيره
وفي اخبار عاجله كمان نتبعها على الشاشه
كما قلنا نقلا عن موقع اكسيوس التحقيق
الامريكي بشان مقتل شاب وعقله يقول امر
غير اعتيادي ويمكن ان يشمل الجنود الذين
شاركوا في هذه
العمليه
وكذلك موقع ولا لساني قال مكتبه تحقيقات
الفيدرالي همم الامريكي فتح تحقيقا جنائيا
بظروف مقتل الصحفيه شيرين ابو عاقله وايضا
عن ذات الموقع وزاره العدل الامريكيه
ابلغت نظيرتها الاسرائيليه بفتح مكتب الاف
بي اي تحقيقا بمقتل الزميله شيرين
وننوه ايضا لهذا الخبر العاجل ايضا عن
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بالنا
الامريكيين ابلغ وزاره العدل ال ال
اسرائيليه بانه تم فتح تحقيق في واشنطن في
بشان مقتل الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله اذا عن
هذه الاخبار المتتاليه معنا من واشنطن
مراسل مراسله الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك ومن
القدس الياس كرم وابدا معك بيسان بهذه
الاخبار
العاجله ما نقله موقع اكسيوس عن همم هذا
التوجه الامريكي الى فتح تحقيق وابلاغ
الجانب الاسرائيلي ذلك
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه ما لدينا هو ما نقله
موقع اكسيوز عبد القادر بانه تم ابلاغ
الجانب الاسرائيليه بهذه النيه لفتح هذا
التحقيق وان هذا التحقيق وفق ما قالته
اكسيوس امر غير اعتيادي وانه سيسفر عن طلب
تحقيقات مع الاشخاص المعنيين ومنهم جنود
اسرائيليين طبعا لا نعلم الرد الاسرائيلي
حتى الان نحن بدورنا ايضا نتواصل مع
الجهات المعنيه هنا للتاكد مما اوردته من
يعني من وزاره العدل الامريكيه بالنسبه
لمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
كان قد قال لي الجزيره ان همم الجهات
المعنيه هي جهات انفذ القانون لتاكيد هذا
الخبر ولكنه تحدث عن شيرين في تعليق اهل
الجزيره بانها طبعا لم تكن منطقه مواطن
امريكيه ولكن كانت صحفيه شجاع
وتنال الاحترام حول العالم ولكن عبد
القادر كما تعلم ايضا ان هذه الخطوه همم
هي تاتي حين طبعا نتاكد منها ايضا من
مصادرنا نحن هنا تاتي بعض ضغوط متواصله من
اعضاء الكونجرس على مدار اشهر لفتح تحقيق
مستقل
وشفاف وفي مصداقيه في ظروف مقتل الزميله
شيرين ابو عاقله رسائل متتاليه وجهت من
قبل الاعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
واعضاء في مجلس النواب الامريكي للوزير
بلينكن وايضا للرئيس الامريكي جو بعيدا له
فتح هذا التحقيق وايضا طبعا له الاف بي اي
نظرا لان المراجعه التي تمت من قبل المنصق
الامني حين تمت قبل عده اشهر البعض هنا
رحب بها ولك ما اعتبروها غير كافيه ولا
تجيب عن الكثير من الاسئله وكان هناك حتى
بيان شديد اللهجه من السيناتور الديمقراطي
باتريك ليه هي قبل نحو شهر يعني قال ان
هذه التحقيقات ضروري جدا وانه امر اعتيادي
وفق قوله ان يفتح تحقيق حين يستهدف مواطن
امريكي وصحفي بهذا الشكل
ما نقله نقله اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
واشنطن ابلغت وزاره العدل الاسرائيليه
باحتمال طلب مواد للتحقيق في وفاه شيرين
ابو عاقله اذا الياس نحن امام خطوه الان
اصبحت مؤكده
هي خطوه متطوره جدا ومتقدمه في سياق هذا
التحقيق في هذه الجريمه التي اودت بحياه
الزميله الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله لكن من
الواضح بان اسرائيل الرسميه حتى هذه
الساعه تلتزم الصمت حيال هذه الانباء التي
اصبحت ربما شبه مؤكده على اعتبار ان وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه وازنه قد تلقفتها على
قدر كبير ووضعتها على صدر صفحاتها الاولى
وفي عناوينها الرئيسيه في المواقع نشير
هنا الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ اللحظه
الاولى من جريمه اغتيال الزميله الراحله
شيرين ابو عقلي قد رفض جمله وتفصيلا فتحه
تحقيق جنائي مع الجنود الذين
تورطوا في هذه الجريمه
والجيش الاسرائيلي قال بانه لن يفتح اي
تحقيق جنائي في هذه الحادثه كما سماها على
اعتبار انه يرسل جنوده الى الميدان
لمحاربه الارهاب وان الزميله شيرين ابو
عاقل وكانه يريد ان يتهم قد تواجدت في
معركه في في ميدان قتال ما بين جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبين مسلحين فلسطينيين كانوا
يطلقون النار بشكل عشوائي وعندما قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه لا يريد ان يفتح
تحقيقا جنائيا هو كان يقصد بانه لن يفتح
تحقيقا ولن يكون هناك تقديم ايضا الجنود
او الضباط الذين تواجد في مسرح الجريمه
للتحقيق في الشرطه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
ومن ثم فتح ملف جنائي في النيابه العسكريه
ضدهم على اعتبار ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرى
بان هذه خطوه غير اخلاقيه نشير هنا ايضا
الى ان التحقيقات التي اجراها الجيش
الاسرائيلي كانت تحقيقات داخليه عسكريه
ميدانيه عملاتيه فقط ولم تتطرق الى اي
جانب من الجوانب الجنائيه لهذه الجريمه
همم
سوى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق في همم ظروف
ما جرى هناك ولم
اسماء الجنود او الضباط المتورطين ولا
اسماء ربما الوحده التي كانت موجوده وعملت
في مخيم جنين في ذلك اليوم رغم ان الوحده
معروفه للجميع وهي وحده دوفان كما ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي رفض اعطاء اي معلومات
حول شخصيه الجنود او نشر اي صور او
معلومات
الاسرائيلي مع هذا الطالب الامريكي في حال
ماذا تعلق الامر بالتحقيق مع جنود اسرائيل
وهذا بالطبع ما سيؤدي الى صدام كبير ما
بين واشنطن وتل ابيب في هذه النقطه تحديدا
وهذا ايضا ربما مكان للتساؤل عن التوقيت
في هذا الاعلان الاعلان عن فتح التحقيق
الجنائي من جانب مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
هل هنالك علاقه ربما مع الانقلاب السياسي
الذي حدث هنا في اسرائيل صعود اليمين
المتطرف ربما هل لهذا علاقه هذا السؤال
يجب ان يطرح وبقوه في هذا التوقيت لكن من
الواضح بان قناه الجزيره وعائله الراحله
شيرين ابو عاقله والمؤسسات الحقوقيه
والصحفيه حول العالم كانت تشكل ضغطا كبيرا
على الاداره الامريكيه في الشهور الاخيره
من اجل فتحي تحقيق من هذا النوع لاعتبار
ان هذا التحقيق ربما يحقق شيئا من العداله
الغائبه للزميل الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله
على اعتبار ان كل التحقيقات التي اجريت
سواء همم التحقيق الامريكي الذي اجره همم
المنسق الامريكي مايك بنزل الذي اشار رغم
انه اجرى تحقيقا بالستين وحقق في الرصاصه
ايضا التي همم قتلت الزميل الراحله شيرين
ابو عقلي وافضل تقريره في نهايه المطاف
الى انه لا يمكن الجزم والتحديد بشكل قاطع
على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي هو من قتل الزميل
ابو عقل وهذا ما اثار حفيظه عائله شيرين
وايضا قناه الجزيره وكذلك الكثيرين من
المراقبين والمتابعين لهذه القضيه التي
اصبحت قضيه عالميه وليست فقط قضيه خاصه
همم كل التحقيقات الصحفيه وكذلك المدعي
العام الفلسطيني ااه اشار بشكل واضح الى
انك انه كان هنالك يتعمد من جانب جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على اصابه الزميل
الراحله شيرين ابو عاقله التي كانت تلبس
البزه الصحفيه الستره الواقيه والخوذه
وكانت مع مجموعه من الصحفي وكل هذه
التحقيقات كانت فندت في السابق همم كل
مزاعم الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي غير روايتنا
واكثر من مره في الايام الاولى في محاوله
للتستر عن هذه الجريمه على ان هنالك كان
قتال او اشتباك مسلحا ما بين مقاتلين
فلسطينيين وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذا
ما نفته كل التحقيقات المحليه والدوليه
جمله وتفصيلا واكدت بان الرصاصه اطلقت من
جانب الجيش الاسرائيلي عمدا باتجاه
الصحفيين وباتجاه الزميله الراحله شيرين
ابو عقل